NARRATOR: As the opening day
of the Second World War fades,
Lemp strains to identify
the ship in front of him.
CHRISTIAN JENTZSCH: It's
behaving, in his opinion,
like an auxiliary cruiser
because it's zig-zagging
and it's blacked out.
And he even imagines to
have seen gun platforms.
NARRATOR: In Lemp's mind,
that is enough proof
this is some kind of
armed enemy ship fair game
to be attacked without warning.
With torpedoes ready--
[non-english speech]
NARRATOR: --a little
before 8:00 PM Lemp
fires the first to U-boat
torpedoes of World War II.
A hydrophone operator
monitors them by the sound
of their propellers.
One speeds towards the target.
But there is a problem
with the second.
It should grow fainter but
instead is getting louder.
Fearing that it will circle
back and strike them,
Lemp orders the U-boat deeper.
It is a scenario they train
for, even in peacetime.
The standard procedure
is to dive below the depth
that a torpedo would pass.
NARRATOR: It could be tight.
U-30 is more than 210 feet long.
And as the bow angles
down, the stern goes up.
They must get the whole
U-boat out of danger.
They have no way to
visually monitor the threat.
Their only source of information
is what the hydrophone operator
can hear.
[propeller whirling]
When the noise
finally fades away,
the torpedo no longer
poses a threat.
Relieved, Lemp surfaces
to investigate.
With darkness falling, he
moves in for a closer look.
The first torpedo
had struck the ship.
But as Lemp surveys
the crippled vessel,
he realizes that
something is wrong.
They check the silhouette of the
large ship against the Lloyd's
Register of vessels.
When he saw the
scene of action,
he realized that
he was mistaken.
It wasn't an auxiliary cruiser.
It was a steamer with a lot
of civilians in the water.
NARRATOR: An intercepted
radio transmission
confirms his fears.
It identifies the ship
as the passenger liner
SS Athenia bound for Canada.
Lemp has made a huge mistake.
His orders were clear.
Sink only warships, troop ships,
and enemy merchant vessels.
Hitler and the
German government
still hope for some
kind of settlement
agreement with Britain.
And so they don't want to
aggravate the British more
than necessary.
NARRATOR: Now, on the
very first day of the war,
Lemp has sunk a passenger
vessel without warning.
Comparisons are immediately made
to the sinking of RMS Lusitania
by a U-boat in World War I, an
act that helped end American
neutrality and brought the
United States into the war
against imperial Germany--
the exact scenario
Hitler hoped to avoid
with his strict instructions.
Now the sinking of Athenia sets
off a new political firestorm.
Many of the 1,103
passengers aboard
are Canadians, Americans,
or European refugees
escaping the war.
118 civilians are dead.
Hitler and his propaganda
minister, Joseph Goebbels,
vehemently deny German
responsibility for the attack.
The man responsible
for Hitler's headache
is 26-year-old [inaudible]
Fritz-Julius Lemp.
CHRISTIAN JENTZSCH:
He was born as a son
of an army officer in China
before the First World War.
He entered the [inaudible]
Marina in 1931.
And he went to the new
created submarine arm in 1936.
NARRATOR: He was
assigned command of
his own Submarine U-30 in 1938.
Lemp recognizes the potential
fallout from his error.
He makes no radio
report of the sinking
and continues his patrol.
He has to keep it secret.
And he decides to stick exactly
to the submarine protocol
for his future attacks.